i am legend gladiator magic mike and
chicken run
hollywood runs on sequels but we didn't
see any of these coming two sequels for
the batman makes sense a sequel to
bullet 50 years later not so much here
are all the movie sequels that you
didn't know were happening
adapted from the book by richard
matheson the 2007 film i am legend
starred will smith as robert neville the
seemingly sole human survivor of an
apocalyptic plague that transformed most
of the world's humans into a terrifying
cross between zombies and vampires
however neville eventually encounters
another pair of survivors a woman and a
young boy who are both also immune to
the virus the ending of the film didn't
leave a lot of room for smith to return
for a sequel since it saw neville
sacrificing himself in order to save the
other two but an alternate ending found
all three heading to a survivor's camp
in possession of a cure this presumably
is the ending the sequel announced in
2022 would follow the announcement
included the news that smith was once
again set to start this time alongside
michael b jordan as the second lead of
the film however not long after im
legend 2 was announced smith made
headlines for slapping chris rock at the
oscars putting the fate of several of
his future projects in jeopardy since
the release would likely come several
years after the incident it's possible
that im legend 2 could still go ahead
with smith attached or since there's no
director attached or plot announced yet
it's also possible that the script could
pivot to follow the original ending of
the film where smith's character died
allowing jordan to carry the movie on
his own
after matt reeves grounded and gritty
new version of batman swooped
successfully into theaters in 2022
earning praise for reeve's direction and
robert pattinson's performance as the
caped crusader it seemed a foregone
conclusion that there would be more
movies to come after all since when has
batman movie ever not gotten the sequel
sure enough the batman is currently
slated to receive not just one but two
sequels the batman reinvented the iconic
batman villain the riddler played by
paul dano as an awkward internet
extremist with a penchant for puzzles
and a bizarre fascination with the
batman in the sequel reeves have said he
would like to similarly reimagine
another classic batman villain
previously seen in a joel schumacher
movie mr freeze
what killed the dinosaurs
the ice age
reeves said in a 2022 press event in my
view i just feel drawn to finding the
grounded version of everything so to me
it would be a challenge in an
interesting way to try and figure out
how that could happen even the idea of
something like mr freeze that's such a
great story right i think there's
actually a grounded version of that
story which could be really powerful and
could be really great the last time we
saw mr freeze on the big screen he was
played by arnold schwarzenegger and had
a fondness for icy puns but it sounds
like reeves version of the character
will be as far removed from arnold's
freeze as dano's riddler was from jim
carrey's on april 26 2022 warner
brothers confirmed that a sequel is in
the works with matt reeves and robert
pattinson returning though no release
date was announced
although the 2021 film based on the hit
video game franchise mortal kombat
didn't especially wow critics it
performed well enough at the box office
and on hbo max to get a sequel greenlit
the script for mortal kombat 2 will come
from the pen of moon knight head writer
jeremy slater but no director is yet in
place for the sequel similarly there's
no word yet on which if any members of
the first film's cast will return for
mortal kombat 2. the plot of mortal
kombat follows a down on his luck mixed
martial arts fighter named cole young
who finds himself being hunted by an
assassin named sub-zero in an effort to
defend himself and his family he seeks
out a group of elite fighters tasked
with protecting the world from
malevolent outside forces a sequel would
presumably pick up where the first film
left off with cole now aware of his
heritage and his destiny and on a
mission to seek out the martial artist
and movie star johnny cage those are 500
sunglasses [ __ ]
[Music]
considering the slew of films from the
80s and 90s being reimagined for modern
audiences it was always going to be just
a matter of time before the bizarre 1988
tim burton haunted house comedy
beetlejuice got the sequel treatment
it's showtime
sure enough beetlejuice 2 is finally in
the works from brad pitt's production
company plan b with michael keaton and
winona ryder each expected to reprise
their roles for the first film
beetlejuice starred keaton as the
titular malevolent spirit who's hired by
a deceased couple adam and barbara
maitland to rid their former home of its
current inhabitants winona ryder played
lydia dietz the teenage daughter of the
new homeowners and the only one of the
living humans who can see the ghosts of
the maitlands by the end of the film the
dietzes and the maitlands are happily
sharing the house while beetlejuice is
banished to an eternal waiting room for
the non-living although the script for
beetlejuice 2 has not yet been written
we imagine it will find him finally
returning to the world of the living to
wreak havoc again
we've got a lot of sequels on this list
that are set to release many years or
even decades after the last installment
in the series but this one may win the
award for longest gap between the
original film and part 2. deadline
reported in february 2022 that steven
spielberg is eyeing a follow-up to the
1968 action thriller bullet as one of
his next projects following his
oscar-nominated remake of west side
story and his upcoming
semi-autobiographical coming of age
drama the fableman's bullet starred
steve mcqueen as san francisco cop frank
bullet working to solve the murder of a
key mob witness who was assassinated
while under his protection deadline
sources report that spielberg's bullet
will not be a remake of the mcqueen film
but rather a new story centered around
the same character although of course
the title rule would need to be recast
mcqueen passed away in 1980. that seems
to mean this film would effectively be a
sequel mcqueen's son chad and
granddaughter molly mcqueen have also
signed on as executive producers for the
film josh singer will be penning the
script for spielberg's bullet but since
no other details or casting are in place
yet it may be a while before we see this
one hit screens
the original a quiet place stayed
focused entirely on one small family
headed by real life couple john
krasinski and emily blunt the sequel
zoomed out a bit bringing the surviving
characters from the first film into
contact with a small peaceful community
that had managed to stay isolated from
the sound seeking monstrosities prowling
the world around them now a third a
quiet place film is on the docket which
will likely once again follow blunt's
character evelyn and her now teenage
children as they come of age in a world
where any sound can lead to a sudden and
grisly death much like the characters in
the films paramount hasn't said much
about this project committing only to a
release date sometime in 2025 this is
separate from another a quiet place film
in the works from writer and director
michael sarnoski which is thought to
take place in the same world but with
different characters at the center of
its story that film is scheduled to hit
theaters september 22nd 2023
sonic the hedgehog is a bona fide
success story beating the odds and a
horrific first trailer to become the
most successful movie series based on a
video game ever the performance of the
sequel sealed that reputation but before
sonic the hedgehog 2 even zoomed onto
screens in april 2022 a third film had
already been greenlit by paramount plot
details about the third film are still
sparse but without getting into spoilers
we can expect a new villain to show up
paramount and sega have also announced a
spin-off television series centered
around knuckles the big brawler of an
echidna who was introduced in the second
movie no release date has been announced
yet for sonic the hedgehog 3 but much
like the blue hedgehog himself we expect
it to move fast
that wasn't too bad
after his oscar-nominated performance as
macbeth in the tragedy of macbeth denzel
washington began prepping to pivot into
a very different role by returning to
the equalizer franchise in this series
washington plays ex-marine robert mccall
who tends to go on violent vigilante
terrors when people he cares about are
harmed basically he's a real-life
superhero the first equalizer film saw
washington's character protecting a
teenage sex worker from the russian
mafia while the second caught up with
him as he avenged the death of one of
his friends from the first film the
equalizer 3 is expected to once again be
directed by antoine fuqua who helmed the
first two films although no official
plot details are known yet fuqua
mentioned in 2018 that he had big plans
to take robert mccall to europe in his
next adventure what we do know now is
that the planned sequel has been given a
release date september 1st 2023. as for
washington he's looking forward to
returning to the role of mccall telling
collider i gotta get in shape and start
beating people up again i get to beat
people up again the tragedy of macbeth
and then going and beating some people
up can't get any better right
i'm gonna kill each and every one of you
and the only disappointment in it for me
is that i only get to do it once when
netflix ponied up its largest chunk of
cash yet for the star-studded
globe-trotting heist film red notice
some wondered if the hefty investment
could possibly pay off for the streamer
apparently the answer is yes as netflix
has signed up for two more red notice
films set to be filmed back to back with
writer and director ross and marshall
thurber we catch it together i can clear
my name and i'll help you become the
number one thief in the world again
the first film saw fbi agent john
hartley teaming up with art thief nolan
booth in order to apprehend the even
more wily thief sarah black the sequel
will reportedly bring back the main mega
star trio of dwayne johnson gal gadot
and ryan reynolds and add a number of
new characters who will team up to pull
off an ensemble heist in the spirit of
ocean's eleven presumably the third film
would build on that idea even more with
even grander heists and more spectacular
action currently production on the two
red noticed sequels is set to start in
early 2023 which means that we can
probably expect red notice 2 tit netflix
sometimes in 2024 with red notice 3 hot
on its heels
before the bodies of the latest victims
of the ghost phase killer even had a
chance to cool off a sequel to 2022's
newest scream installment had already
been greenlit by paramount the fifth
installment in the scream franchise the
2022 film once again saw sydney prescott
gail weathers and dewey reilly on the
run from a serial killer in a ghost face
mask along with a host of new characters
many of whom were fated for a bloody end
scream was well received by both
audiences and critics leading the studio
to move ahead with plans for the next
film in the franchise the sixth scream
film will once again be helmed by the
filmmaking trio radio silence the plot
of scream films are always kept heavily
under wraps but courtney cox has already
confirmed that she'll be appearing in
the next film and we can only hope that
nev campbell will be right behind her
production on the newest screen is set
to begin in june 2022 with a release
date of march 31st 2023
even ahead of the release of despicable
me spin-off feature minions the rise of
gru universal is looking ahead to the
next installment in the main franchise
despicable me 4 which is slated to hit
theaters july 3rd 2024. the animated
despicable me films center around a
reformed super villain named gru who
leaves his dastardly ways behind him
after adopting a trio of adorable
daughters and discovering the joys
frustrations and responsibilities of
parenthood aided by his troop of
gibberish-speaking yellow minions gru
has spent each despicable me film
venturing into the unfamiliar world of
heroism in an effort to make the world a
safer place for his family while we
don't know the plot for despicable me 4
yet we can only imagine it will once
again see gru face off against a
dastardly villain to save the world even
though he admires their diabolical plan
just a little bit
it's time for a whole new generation of
kids to worry about shooting their eyes
out
several decades after the classic
holiday film a christmas story was first
released a sequel is in the works a
christmas story christmas will bring
back peter billingsley as ralphie the
elementary age protagonist of the first
film now all grown up and facing the
holidays yet again in the 1970s also
returning for the sequel are ian
patrella as ralphie's brother randy
along with zach ward scott schwartz and
rd robb as ralphie's trio of friends and
foes from school the movie is set to
follow ralphie returning to his
childhood home in an attempt to give his
own children a christmas like the ones
he experienced as a kid during his visit
ralphie will reconnect with his old
friends and revisit his own memories of
a christmas no one could ever forget the
movie is set to be released exclusively
on hbo max
buckle up and prepare to laugh because a
sequel to the 2017 comedy girls trip is
on the way the first film starred regina
hall queen latifah tiffany haddish and
jada pinkett smith has four friends who
decide to travel to a music festival
together but wind up having a much more
entertaining story to tell by the time
it's all said and done all four cast
members are expected to return for girls
trip 2 which was announced by producer
will packer during an interview with
good morning america in early 2022 all
that's left to find out is where the
girls end up this time
how much did she drink
following three successful films in the
rebooted planet of the apes franchise a
fourth is on the way from the maze
runner director west ball and
screenwriter josh friedman the three
films with the last two helmed by the
batman director matt reeves seemed to
reach their natural end with 2017's war
for the planet of the apes but 20th
century studios announced after the
conclusion of the trilogy that another
apes film was in the works this time
under ball's direction which he said on
twitter in 2020 would continue caesar's
legacy of course caesar voiced and
performed via motion capture by andy
serkis the leader of the apes in the
first three films ended the third movie
mortally wounded leading to speculation
that ball was actually referring to
caesar's son cornelius since then news
on a fourth planet of the apes film has
been scarce leading some to wonder
whether it was even happening but in a
2022 interview with the hollywood
reporter 20th century studios president
steve asbill assured us that the film
was still moving forward saying we are
expecting a draft very shortly and it's
west ball attached to direct we hope to
go by the late summer early fall
considering how many special effects go
into these movies we're still not
expecting to see it on screens anytime
soon but it sounds like in a couple
years the apes will rise again
it's been almost 20 years since
audiences followed effervescent sorority
girl l woods to harvard law school and
the bubblegum hewed legally blonde she
continued to ascend the professional
ladder in 2003's legally blonde 2 red
white and blonde which saw elle head to
washington dc now l is back for a third
go-around reese witherspoon will also
act as a producer this time through her
hello sunshine banner and she's brought
on never have i ever creator mindy
kaling and brooklyn nine-nine creator
dan goor to pen the screenplay also
returning for the sequel is jennifer
coolidge who starred in both previous
films as elle's friend paulette a
character who kaling teased will have a
really juicy role in the film i can't
wait to see what l woods what people
think of the way that we wrote l woods
at 40.
audiences were first introduced to the
character of puss and boots in 2004's
shrek 2 where the ferocious feline was
hired as an assassin to take out the big
green ogre of course he never managed to
carry out his mission and the film ended
with the two characters on the same side
voiced by antonio banderas universal
deemed the character of puss in boots
popular enough to warrant its own
spin-off which was released in 2011. the
sequel subtitled the last wish will
follow the courageous kitty now on his
ninth life as he searches for the
mythical last wish that he hopes will
restore the other eight lives he lost
when you only have one life
that's what makes it special
plus in boots the last wish is set to
release on september 23 2022
the next film in paramount's transformer
series will be titled transformers rise
of the beasts the film will bring back
popular autobots such as optimus prime
and bumblebee while introducing several
new to the film's beast wars characters
such as optimus primal who will be
voiced by ron perlman despite sharing
some characters the movie reportedly
won't be picking up where the last one
left off marking another clean start for
the sprawling franchise if it does well
paramount has hinted that it may spark a
new transformers trilogy transformers
rise of the beasts is set in theaters
june 9th 2023
after the success of the first movie in
theaters and on hbo max doom part 2 was
officially greenlit the first dune began
a sprawling tale of feuding households
political maneuvering religious intrigue
and resource mining on the desert planet
of arrakis told through an impressive
ensemble cast of course not all the
central players in dune survived until
the end but those that did are expected
to reprise their roles in the sequel
including timothy chalamet as paul
tradies and zendaya as the mysterious
channey also returning our director
denis villeneuve and composer han zimmer
the latter of whom joked in a tweet
thank goodness i have some music left as
for villeneuve the director clarified
that he considers dune part 2 the same
movie as doom rather than a traditional
sequel telling the hollywood reporter
it's not a sequel where it's another
episode or another story with the same
characters it actually has direct
continuity to the first movie it's the
second part of the big huge movie that
i'm trying to do
only together
can we stand a chance
paramount is preparing a fourth star
trek film in the current franchise which
would bring back the cast of 2009 star
trek one division director matt shakman
has signed on to helm the project
working off a script from lindsey beer
and geneva robertson dwarit one weird
hurdle the news reportedly came as a
surprise to the series actors when asked
about the film in march 2022 carl urban
who plays dr leonard bones mccoy in the
franchise had this to say to variety i
haven't seen a script i know nothing but
i would love to work with those guys
again so much fun the best tank we'll
see star trek four is set to hit
theaters on december 22 2023
on his 35th birthday in 1988 julius
benedict was informed that he was
separated at birth from his twin brother
vincent after they were both conceived
in a lab as part of a genetic experiment
twins followed the unlikely duo as they
reconnected and uncovered the
long-buried secrets about their past now
33 years later the benedict clan is
growing yet again in triplets the sequel
will bring back arnold schwarzenegger
and danny devito as julius and vincent
and they'll be joined by tracy morgan as
a yet unnamed third brother following
the death of director ivan reitman the
status of the film felt uncertain but
during an appearance at the arnold
sports festival in 2022 schwarzenegger
seemed confident that triplets would
eventually move forward instead of
triplets that's a project that was
supposed to be filmed in october and so
it could still be you know but we just
have to now look into a different
director and see if we are going to
continue with this project
in 2015 mad max fury road reinvigorated
the long dormant mad max franchise which
began in 1979 with mel gibson in the
title role fury road offered a new spin
on the post-apocalyptic tale casting tom
hardy as max and shifting focus to
charlize theron's rage field imperator
furiosa mad max fury road wowed
audiences and critics alike with many
considering it one of the best action
films of all time so it seemed that
sequels would be inevitable
we could ask for anything
i want to drive to warwick
sure enough five years after fury road
roared into theaters two follow-up films
are in the works one of which is a
direct sequel while the other is a
prequel centered around a younger
furiosa the sequel which has been given
the working title mad max the wasteland
was reportedly greenlit by warner
brothers in early 2020 and will follow
hardy's max rocketansky but won't
feature the return of furiosa while
furiosa will bring back the title
character theron herself won't be making
an appearance in that film either
director george miller said that as much
as he loved theron's performance in fury
road he doesn't have enough faith in
de-aging technology to allow theron to
reprise her role for the prequel instead
the younger furiosa will be played by
anya taylor joy and she'll be joined by
mcu star chris hemsworth who will
reportedly be playing a villain named dr
dementis i'm just so excited i know that
whatever person i will be at the end of
it will be remarkably different than the
person i am now
miller and co-writer nico lutherus
developed origin stories for every
character while preparing fury road in
fact letharus wrote an entire screenplay
for furiosa in the process curiosa is
set to tear into theaters on may 27 2024
in april 2018 the hollywood reporter
announced that aardman animations will
be revisiting the hens and roosters of
chicken run in a brand new sequel while
the follow-up film was originally
intended for theaters netflix announced
in 2020 that the streamer would actually
be the home of the chicken run sequel
and will be released in 2023. the
screenplay for chicken run 2 titled
chicken run dawn of the nugget is being
crafted in part by carrie kirkpatrick
and john o'farrell both of whom worked
on the original chicken run as for the
director the film is in the fine
stop-motion hands of sam phil the
filmmaker behind paranorman the story
will once again feature rocky and ginger
now living happily in a human-free
island sanctuary with their young chick
molly but when chickens come under
threat yet again rocky and ginger decide
to leave their peaceful home to once
again fight for all chicken kind
the original clerks released in 1994
followed a pair of clerks who worked at
a combination video rental shop slash
convenience store and took place in and
around the store the follow-up 2006's
clerks 2 follows the same characters a
decade later after a fire at the quick
stop has forced them to start working at
a fast food restaurant the third film
will return to the quick stop and will
follow randall asking his friends to
help him tell his life story by making
an indie film after suffering a heart
attack while clerks 3 doesn't have a
release date yet kevin smith revealed in
february 2022 that post-production on
the film was finished and that we would
likely see a trailer sometime in may
given that timeline we can probably
expect to see clerks 3 hit theaters
sometime in late 2022 or early 2023
den of thieves might have been a flop
with critics but this heist thriller got
away with 80 million dollars at the box
office and in hollywood crisp dollar
bills talk way louder than rotten
tomatoes leading to the announcement of
a sequel just weeks after the first film
hit theaters den of thieves 2 pantera
will reunite original film stars gerard
butler o'shea jackson jr and meta
williams with writer director christian
gudegast so you can drive huh
oh i could drive according to deadline
the film will follow gerard butler's big
nick searching for o'shea jackson
junior's donny in europe while the
master thief plans his next big heist
deadline further reports that once again
gurgaos spent time with both certified
thieves and the people who pursue them
as part of his research for the film
currently den of thieves 2 pantera has
no release date but with filming set to
start in late spring 2022 the wait for
more pulse-pounding heist action
shouldn't be long
after the smash success of 2020's enola
homes netflix detective young adult
caper starring millie bobby brown is the
younger sister of sherlock holmes the
streamer has greenlit a sequel that will
bring back both home siblings for
another twisting caper based on a series
of novels by nancy springer the first
film saw teenage anola running away from
home to investigate her mother's
mysterious disappearance against the
explicit instructions of her older
brother mycroft who steps in as her
guardian during her journey she
befriends the vi count tewksbury
marquess of basil weather a young
runaway who's been targeted for
assassination of course by the end of
the film manola has solved both
mysteries as well as earned the respect
of her famous detective sibling the
second film which will hit the streamer
sometime in 2022 will see the newly
minted detective once again taking on an
intriguing case the synopsis reads now a
detective for hire like her infamous
brother enola holmes takes on her first
official case to find a missing girl as
the sparks of a dangerous conspiracy
ignite a mystery that require the help
of friends and sherlock himself to
unravel
and those kind of mysteries are always
the most satisfying to unpick
as bizarre action movie premises go it
doesn't get much weirder than the
original face-off which starred nicholas
cage and john travolta as a terrorist
and an fbi agent who literally swapped
faces via a gnarly surgery in order to
take each other's place yet even though
cage's villainous caster troy is killed
at the end of the first film a direct
sequel is now in the works from
filmmakers adam wingard and simon
barrett while original reports assumed
that the new face-off film would be a
reboot with a totally new cast taking on
the story barrett and wingard were quick
to clarify on social media that they had
no intention of reimagining the original
which wingard wrote was a perfect action
movie wingard and barrett have
previously worked together on
pulse-pounding films such as you're next
and the guest suggesting they're more
than capable of taking on the violently
wacky tone of a face-off sequel
wait you get looking
speaking to the associated press in
august 2021 cage expressed enthusiasm at
the possibility of reprising his role
for the sequel saying i would love to
get back into that character and to work
with travolta again absolutely that was
such a fun movie to make of course with
troy dead at the end of the first film
bringing back the original stars could
be tricky it's also worth noting that
cage later muddied the waters saying in
a march 2022 interview with the
hollywood reporter i have not heard hide
nor hair about face off 2. so often
these things we read about are just
conjecture without any base or
foundation to it then again cage
wouldn't be the first actor to deny
involvement in a film he's secretly in
it's also possible the movie could go
forward with or without his involvement
we thought this day would never come but
it looks like ridley scott is heading
back to ancient rome nearly 20 years
after the original gladiator hit
theaters scott is finally making a
sequel to the story of maximus decimus
meridius of course old maximus is busy
walking through wheat fields in heaven
so what's the sequel going to be about
well according to producer walter f
parks the film is going to start about
25 to 30 years after the original ended
and according to the hollywood reporter
part 2 will focus on lucius the son of
maximus's old flame lucilla the initial
screenplay for the film came from peter
craig whose previous credits include the
town and 2022's the batman but was
subsequently worked on by david scarpa
who also wrote scott's yet to be
released film about napoleon scott
revealed in late 2021 that the script is
already complete and gladiator 2 is
queued up to be the director's next
project once he's finished with napoleon
with ridley scott once again at the helm
we're pretty sure we'll be entertained
the team responsible for the kingsman
films at one point had ambitious plans
for a whopping seven more kingsman
installments a tall order by any measure
now director matthew vaughn seems a
little more restrained in his planning
telling the hollywood reporter in
december 2021 that he's got two more
sequels ready to go and if they work
then one step at a time still the
franchise has built in plenty of room
for more storytelling while the first
two kingsmen film starred taryn edgerton
as the newly minted british secret agent
eggsy 2021's the king's man is a prequel
focused on the early days of the
kingsman agency civilized
but merciless
so far we've heard of a potential third
exec-centric film and a spin-off focused
on the american counterparts to the
kingsman introduced in the second film
titled statesman no release is yet
scheduled for either of these films nor
any of the others but it looks like we
can still expect more kingsman
adventures in whatever form they take
probably not many predicted back in 2012
that the channing tatum led
semi-autobiographical stripper film
magic mic would go on to spawn a
successful trilogy but the magic is set
to continue in magic mike's last stance
original director steven soderbergh is
returning to the director's chair and
tatum will reprise his role as mike lane
while the first magic mike centered
around a teen played by alex pettifer
first entering the world of stripping
tatum's mic took center stage in the
2015 sequel magic mike double xl which
saw a retired mike donning his rip away
pants once more to join his friends on a
road trip to a stripping convention in
myrtle beach the plot of magic mike's
last dance is still under wraps but
soderbergh has offered a few teases of
what to expect including seeing mike in
a serious relationship for the first
time he told collider in early 2022 the
third movie is the sort of apex of
everything that we've been talking about
in that area not just taking the dancing
to another level but really getting into
the relationship aspect that's been an
undercurrent in all of the films salma
hayek is playing the female lead
replacing original actor tanduay newton
who will most likely help mike lane's
last magic dance be the best it can be
magic mike's last dance will be released
exclusively on hbo max
when the megs swam into the public
consciousness some might have scoffed at
this ridiculous sounding jaws rip-off
but this megalodon movie earned some
serious coin at the box office drawing
528 million dollars worldwide against
its 130 million dollar budget after all
this is a movie where jason statham goes
to war with a gigantic shark who doesn't
want to see that
megalodon
he's kidding right
after audiences went into a feeding
frenzy for the film plans were almost
immediately set in motion for a sequel
in october 2020 warner brothers
confirmed that rebecca and high-rise
filmmaker ben wheatley will be helming
the shark-tastic sequel filming for
meg-2 began in january 2022 so hopefully
it won't be long before the sequel swims
onto screens
ahead of the release of spyral from the
book of saw the ninth installment in the
saw horror franchise star chris rock was
already campaigning for a sequel
speaking to radiotimes.com rock said i
hope this movie is like creed in the
sense that creed is technically like
rocky 7. so hopefully there's more
spirals and hopefully i'm in more
spirals but we'll see we'll see if
people like it we'll see if people turn
out people did indeed turn out with
spyral's theatrical take pushing the
horror franchise over the 1 billion mark
at the global box office but even
without knowing how much spiral would
make bloody disgusting reported ahead of
release that lionsgate was in active
development on a tenth saw film although
that hasn't yet been confirmed by the
studio in december 2021 josh stolberg
who co-wrote spiral alongside pete
goldfinger posted a photo on twitter of
both writers alongside producers matt
berg and orrin kulas claiming the group
is already polishing up the script he
also dropped a tease that is sure to
delay itself ends writing this is going
to make jon kramer fans very happy john
cramer of course is the real name of
jigsaw indicating that the franchise's
iconic and deceased villain may make a
shocking comeback in the spiral sequel
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]